Now that we've gone over how to communicate from some kind of player or user input into Pawn, some kind of character in the world.
Let's talk about how we actually communicate with that character and the world now, so to do this we talk about blueprint interfaces.
So this is just an overview of the blueprint interface, we'll get hands-on inside of an engine with a quick tutorial on how to use them.
But to give you the high level information right now, so we have two different blueprint interfaces here.
We have a use interface where the player directly uses an actor in the level.
So the player presses a button, they want something to happen, it sends out a message that says I want to use something, is there anything to use here?
And then there's another blueprint interface that can receive an activation message that says I have been used, do something here.
So one interface sends out a message that says I want to use something, and then another interface says I have been used, do X action.
And again, the high level concept is that we're sending out a message to be received from one blueprint to another blueprint and we're just checking if another blueprint can receive this message.
That's the easiest way to think about that concept.
When we are sending out these use object messages, they come in the form of an event.
And you'll see this little icon here which looks like a little blueprint with a cog and some arrows, that is the global icon for blueprint interface.
So whenever you see that, that's what a blueprint interface is.
And so when we're talking about using them, a really good practice to get into whenever you have variables that could be any number of actors, actor types, shall we say, you want to check if it's valid.
You want to say, is this variable valid? Does it have some kind of property that can be used?
So it's really good to prevent errors, check the references early.
Later down the line, they cause compile or even crash issues.
So getting into the habit of using an is valid is a really useful workflow and you don't just need to use it with blueprint interfaces either.
They can be across the board, just getting into using is valid.
So we can drag off the blue pin or whichever kind of pin you have as a variable and then you can type is valid and you'll get this kind of function
that only executes if this variable here has some kind of information that can be used.
Another way to get is valid is you can right click on this blue pin of your variable here and you can convert it to a get is valid.
And that will give you this kind of box. So it's still the same variable, it still has an activatable target, which is the same here.
But now we have two execution pins, which are the same execution pins as the top image, but it's just a little bit cleaner way of working.
So both will do the exact same thing and then that's up to you how you decide to use it in your workflow.
Then the last thing to cover is a does implement interface.
So when we're using these interfaces, when maybe we have an activatable target and we have this object here,
and then whatever interface we've created, we could select that interface from this drop down here.
And we want to say, does this thing that we're looking at, say it's a light switch in this instance,
does it implement the use interface class that we created? And if it does, okay, cool.
We'll continue and fire continue the execution of whichever logic we have.
So again, we're just kind of securely checking that everything is correct before we fire certain functionality
to make sure the thing that we're trying to interact with is of the right class.